well it is an important American Ally
and it is in turmoil a late night deal
is said to have been struck with Yemen's
besiege president who has now given into
to demands by iranian-backed Shiite
Rebels this is a way to diffuse a
political crisis that has now engulfed
this us Ally and the question is how
long will it last and how does this then
change the fight on power let's bring in
Robert Spencer of jiadi watch good to
have you here this morning sir good to
be here thank you so there's whole bunch
of stories kind of developing out of the
Middle East that are really big and I
want to start with this issue in Yemen
because obviously there's been this you
know uh lawlessness going on for the
last little while while these Rebels go
in they took the the palace Under Siege
and the president in order to you know
unlock himself essentially had to give
into the demands what does it mean
where's the power shift now well it
means a victory for Iran because the
rebels are Shiite they are backed by
Iranian money and weaponry and they have
now got won guarantees from the
president that they will have an
increased role in the governance of the
state sure and so Iran will have more
influence in Yemen and uh this will not
necessarily hamper the fight that the US
has been waging against al-Qaeda in
Yemen because the Iranians hate Al-Qaeda
as much as the United States does the
problem is however with the combining
this with the new Russian agreement with
Iran it's just strengthening Iran across
the board and that could Bode very ill
for the United States in the near future
yeah let's talk a little bit about that
deal because I I was shocked and I don't
know how much truth to this is because
it's not getting a lot of reportage but
Russia has agreed to give Iran a a
missile defense system um this to me is
absolutely ludicrous uh theoretically
Iran backed by uh Russia will not only
have capability of of more nuclear power
because if if America does not get this
deal in place they could have nuclear uh
bomb at some point but with this this
missile Shield they will literally be
Untouchable yes and Vladimir Putin you
know he has been very clear as to what
he's trying to do he's trying to restore
Russia as a world power and that means
to a great degree restoring the Cold War
yeah and so he's moving obviously to
make agreements with Iran in order to
weaken the United States and to put us
in a very difficult position and the
events in only Aid that effort yeah the
cold war with a nuclearized Iran is a
lot more frightening than a cold war of
what we know from the past and so you
know the president during the estate of
the Union hardly talked about the issue
of Terror he was so going on about his
wonderful accomplishments everywhere
else but you know some of his highest
ranking Democrats are now even speaking
out um on the issues of of how he's
playing his foreign policy Bob Menendez
who's a senator uh was saying that it's
like he's getting his plays right out of
of Teran take a listen to what he had to
say I have to be honest with you the
more I hear from the administration and
its quotes uh the more it sounds like
talking points that come straight out of
Teran and it feeds to the Iranian
Narrative of
victimization uh when they are the ones
with original SL an illicit nuclear
weapons program going back uh over the
course of 20 years that they are
unwilling to come clean
on so I don't know why we feel compelled
to make their
case I don't understand why this is not
getting bigger play in the media because
Iran with a nuclear capability is about
the worst thing that can happen
especially given the situation that it
is now now the GOP obviously you know
that they've invited Netanyahu to come
and speak they've gone around the
president on the issue
on this um where do you sense that this
is going is the GOP going to meet with
Netanyahu to try to build something and
somehow get uh you know sanctions in
place or something to stop Iran from
nuclearized yeah that seems to be what
Boehner has in mind uh that's what he
said that he was going to uh not make
any promises about new sanctions on Iran
he was going to resist the president in
trying to make a bad deal with Iran and
bring Netanyahu to Congress obviously is
all part of the same initiative whether
he will follow through or not that's
another matter because Boehner's been
notoriously weak and given into Obama so
many times in the past that uh it's it's
Highly Questionable that he'll pull
anything off but uh the statement from
Menendez was remarkable that was great
uh that's the kind of thing that the
media ought to be saying and that but
instead of course you know they they
they avoid everything in the mainstream
that makes Obama look bad and so even
when he is capitulating ENT to Iran and
enabling this Russian uh effort and this
Iranian effort that could be disastrous
for the United States and its allies
they don't have anything to say about it
because they have to protect their man
all right and so what's what in your um
opinion when when is the timeline for a
nuclearized Iran how quickly are these
developments going to stop and can they
stop Russia from from putting in this
missile defense Shield then the how
quickly Iran will be able to develop a
nuclear weapon is something that nobody
agrees on and has been dis argued about
for years uh clearly they're working
toward it uh clearly time is short
clearly the uh states that have an
interest in stopping them should act
sooner rather than later uh but I don't
want to give any estimates I've seen so
many people give estimates and say Oh
They'll have a bomb in six months
they'll have a bomb in a year you never
know but uh certainly they want to they
have genocidal aspirations and they have
to be stopped and the problem is Obama
shows no interest in stopping no he
doesn't and uh two years to me is far
too long so I hope uh the GOP can do
something or the media at least picks up
on this and starts putting more pressure
you know he claimed during the State of
the Union that you know for what little
he did talk about the situation with
Isis you know he said that they were not
spreading any longer in Syria and he
kind of painted it as you know this is a
problem over there we don't have to
worry about it here so he's either
completely living with unicorns in a
fantasy land or he doesn't understand or
care to fix this problem well he's
covering up for the fact that the
Islamic State exists because of his
failed policy and so now he's boasting
that they have they've stopped their
expansion well they control a territory
great larger in size than Great Britain
and so this is a victory this is a
disastrous defeat if he was saying
they're rapidly losing territory which
they aren't then he might be able to
portray that as a victory but what he
said was absolutely ridiculous yeah you
know Isis reports coming in that they're
recruiting now in Yemen not a lot of
them Al-Qaeda is still the overriding
you know faction there but the fact that
they're there now um is problematic
because they're spreading all over the
place they are they're there they're in
Afghanistan they're recruiting the
Taliban doesn't have any problem with
that apparently maybe the Taliban is
going to sign on to this calip idea uh
this could become a much larger problem
than it is now in the very near future
yeah interesting times scary times
nonetheless I appreciate your insight
into this Robert thanks so much thank
you Robert Spen are joining us this
morning